what did Jesus come here to teach us
I mean talk about someone who came to to
teach us everything that we've just been
talking about you know if there was a
teacher on sovereignty it was Jesus you
know because he embodied and we talk
about a lot in the Sofia what we call
Sophia Christ Consciousness and and
that's the Consciousness he always
taught be in this world but not of this
world whatever you call God or Source or
Spirit when you have a direct when you
know you have your direct connection to
that Source you can download Solutions
healing light intelligence
anything it's all available in the field
yes it's all there
matches tune your frequency absolutely
and so you know although it does seem to
refer to a religion there's a whole
Unity Source movement that has taken the
word Christ back from the from you know
different dogmatic uses in religion to I
to represent like this is how Jesus
walked the Earth how did he form these
Miracles how did he reach So Many Lives
why are we still talking about him to
this day you know his heart was so big
like what is he embodying for us we have
hearts just like his heart and we need
to be using them when you say heart you
mean energy I mean the feeling and the
energy and the Stargate that the heart
chakra is which is also what I'm writing
about um this year and my journey
um
mother Mary speaks it's
um the heart is a Stargate for the soul
so if you are a walking Stargate and you
are checked out of your body you're not
accessing your heart you're not
accessing your true power to not just
change the world literally transform the
world
yeah birth something totally new it's
it's it's
where what source wants to deliver into
this world it's where it lands at the
very center of your being so it can
radiate out and impact you know every
part of you
how you grounded the Earth how you open
up to the Brilliance of your soul yeah
what about the relationship that Jesus
had with Mary Magdalene and getting into
like the alchemical not only the Divine
masculine feminine Union but then the
alchemical
marriage within the self I know that for
a lot of your audience it's it's not any
new knowledge that you know Jesus was
trained in India and Tibet by Master
extreme Masters uh masters of the
highest order but so was Mary Magdalene
and we we talk about that in the Sofia
code she came from an extraordinary
family probably one of the richest
families
um in Palestine at that time and
um her mother had a secret divine
feminine practice
and her father had a secret mystery
school network you know this woman Mary
Magdalene is you know which you know
they wrote total lies about her in the
traditional Bible
um a composite of multiple Mary's that
they lied about in the and so when we
meet Mary magdal and Sophia code we meet
This brilliant psychic
um young woman that was trained as a
high priestess in Egypt as well as India
Mesopotamia temples that um you know
were still operating at that time her
connection to Isis her connection to
segment her connection to Kali
profound so you know when she finally
met Jesus
um you know her her spiritual mother was
already Mother Mary so mother Mary was
already mentoring her for a public
Ministry that you know women at the time
could be stoned to death for speaking
out loud
um teachings and so
this is I get really excited talking
about their Ministry because it's it's
so special what they did and and it
reads like a movie in the Sophia code
and watching it and channeling it
writing it down was one of the greatest
honors of my life but you know what they
don't write about those fields is that
that Jesus was teaching it was like
those were the fields that Mary
Magdalene like spent her Divine in her
her inheritance on to ensure Jesus could
actually be teaching publicly in that
way to thousands of people and she
taught him things
meaning she would she would pay for all
of for for creating those experiences
where people could actually show up and
meet thousands of people really like she
was like like she was like yeah she
booked events
she kind of produced events yeah
that's a really great way to put it well
she I mean she literally she was given
her inheritance whether she chose to
marry or not like her parents were
absolutely from the future in the sense
of they they were so non-traditional and
they so understood who she was in her
own right as an avatar in Christ to
being and so they let her they let her
be strong in her in her sovereignty of
what she really was there was yeah and
she still had to use her mystery school
training to hide that right because at
this time so it was this interesting
Dynamic where she was so empowered at
home and in her mystery school at Mark
Mount Carmel but then she would have to
go into public with Jesus right and so
she would be teaching side by side with
him they'd both be in full Lotus you
think about these Masters these yogurts
together yeah like yeah it's in the
Sofia code they're sitting side by side
in full Lotus position and they're both
performing exorcisms on the masses side
by side and what Jesus would do and they
we talk about this in Sofia code he
would expand his Consciousness so that
the men and women who would judge her
for being in her full yogic power would
actually protect her so that they could
accept and receive her transmission as a
master in her own right her gifts in
skills were so extraordinary and we call
her she of a Thousand Angels in the
Sofia called she would go forth and send
Angels ahead of Jesus and her arrival to
these fields to clear the Demonic
influences like she was doing shamanic
and then he would like set the field
yeah they were they were crazy he would
like yes he would expand his energy
bubble essentially to protect her while
she was doing her thing but before they
got there she would send the angels to
clear the space from
evil demonic energies that would
interfere with the work I mean they were
they were doing high priest and high
priestess work of the highest Magi order
the highest order so when people you
know not all but a lot of people talk
lightly about Mary magdalene's path with
Tantra with Jesus in him just like uh-uh
you had no idea the level of Magic the
level of
um training and Mastery and and how they
were consciously working together as
masters of light for thousands of people
to be transformed from the luciferian
grip of their day like they were so
selfless they were so loving they were
so intelligent they were so creative
they were so psychic it was so far
beyond like this is my boyfriend Jesus
you know what I mean it was like are you
kidding me like you sit down and close
your eyes yeah I'm like they were doing
they were leading a movement that was
saving the planet I mean people you
would walk basically I literally like
imagine walking down the street and just
have the streets lined with people being
crucified I mean that was the form of
Roman punishment of the day it wasn't
reserved for someone like Jesus it it
was just everywhere wherever they lived
you would see people strung up on
crosses so like we we have this idea
that it was like a once in a while thing
it was like this is the kind of extreme
torture the Roman Empire was using to
oppress
um you know the different countries that
they that they would um take over and so
the Jewish people were living under such
extreme tyrannical conditions not to
mention that they already had extreme
conditions at the time for women being
in their power you know so it's like
women were property and if a woman did
anything out of line out of the Pharisee
codes it was just like they could
literally be stoned to death at any
point so the fact that Mary Magdalene
and Jesus were using
what is high level Tantra high level
Tantra I mean can it be experienced
through sexual Union absolutely but it
is the sexual Union is not the
definition of Tantra Tantra is when we
experience total communion with all that
is total communion with the Earth total
communion with your Divinity total
communion with every cell of your body
total God communion Source communion
Universal communion you have two
individuals that are embodying total
communion and presence and then you and
then within the relationship with one
another they are doing such
extraordinary things with their human
bodies it destroys any concept that we
have of what Tantra is and whatever we
think our modern context is and the
reason why I speak so passionately about
it is because I feel strange even
talking about it out loud because what
they were doing was so holy brings tears
to my acts like it is so pure like it is
the definition of what Isis talks about
in the Sophia code about you know your
sexuality being a pathway to recognizing
your true Divinity we're not talking
about you feeling better about your
self-esteem or like you're you know
having a an ego lift we're talking about
God communion and what are you gonna do
with that God communion in your
sexuality in Your Divine Purpose in your
creativity in your service to the light
in your service to Humanity's Awakening
to a sovereignty that that is that's
that is the Tantra of full beingness
if you like this clip and you want to
hear the whole episode click at the
bottom of your screen